[Music]
[Applause]
uh update the pull results and then
we'll bring in uh Pat conon the buck
shooting guard early results Dan on how
thick is your wallet over an inch under
an inch right now we're we're closer to
a 50/50 split than you'd believe do you
think pad has a wallet on him Paulie
does do you think Pat has a wallet he
seems pretty hip he may have one of
those phones where you put your stuff in
the
I think I think Pat is an old school guy
he's got a wallet and I'm going to guess
it's in the front pocket okay 29% of our
audience have a they go front pocket
they go uh we didn't do front pocket but
over one inch thick it's a good solid
30% uh Paulie you ready with the drum
roll the buck shooting guard played at
Notre Dame NBA champ in 2021 Pat conon
is joining us here in Dublin here he
goes and here he is here he goes all
right giving all right love to the back
row will there be D for will there is
broh hug broh hug that's nice all right
hi Pat good to see you yeah uh you know
the big question obviously is going to
be uh do you have a oh you go front
front pocket front
Bo is that plaid he's got a plaid wallet
wow that is thing is gorgeous that's
awesome okay all right dangerous right
front pocket wallet how much money do
you have in your wallet Pat oh um that's
a good question I don't have any um I
don't have any Euros like will okay uh a
lot of them American dollars M yeah what
do we got will count it if he wants to
he wants to count it um I have more than
usual because I'm playing some golf over
here and I was worried about losing some
bets okay uh where are you playing so I
played at Adair Manor few days that
gorgeous I played at the k club that is
awesome uh about a half hour ago and
then uh I'm playing at port marnar on
Saturday right before the game all right
I played uh played those uh Port marck
made the mistake on the first te of
still being wobbly from the night before
and I near nearly put it in the plate
glass window of the people having uh
breakfast what hole was that that was
that was one oh okay good just get so
stay away from the plate Class Window
one exactly yeah or stay away from
trouble I think Will's going to tell me
I have no money in my wallet any be in
his about 4 inch thick wallet will how
much money does Pat big time NBA guy
have you do play in the NBA right I do I
do I do okay this is y's got all the
money this is a disarmingly low amount
of money yeah thank you I app put it
back it yeah I'm not going on your level
yet what do you what do you think what
would happen if you went to a court here
in Dublin just started planning uh you
know so I'm actually out here doing some
clinics uh with the Irish national team
basketball Ireland uh for some kids with
my foundation and so I've been at two
courts I'm going to do one more tomorrow
uh if anybody wants to get some 101 in
at like one o'clock um I'm looking
directly at you no well do you want a
piece of if you can move it up can you
move it up to 11 sure yeah we can make
anything 100% I can make 11 play in my
new shoes oh yeah you got new shoes no
no he does I got him I got him some
dress dress shoes dress shoes but he
doesn't have the shirt off your back
I'll give him I'll give him this shirt
off my back absolutely do you do you
have a question for will before we get
started uh I don't have a question my
initial question was going to be why you
gave my guy Brady Quinn such a hard time
then my next question was going to be if
you ran that Boston Marathon and you
wore that shirt for me because you knew
I was from
Boston I did not oh uh I wore it because
I did I I did run the race that's
awesome uh 356 11 wow 11 was that in
2016 12 2003 wow I was there 2003 okay
were were you cheering I was cheering
yeah I was only 10 yeah but I was
cheering loudly signed your autograph by
the way just in case well he was moving
pretty fast clip I don't think he could
have sign I do remember going up
Heartbreak Hill and where there's a fair
amount of people cheering you on and a
guy start joins the race running next to
me and hands me a
beer and Heartbreak Hill which is at the
20 mile Mark you're in severe pain yeah
and I slapped the beer out of his hand
and said not
now and just kept going which is the
only time that's ever happened when I've
been offered a beer but uh yeah that was
that was a so it could have been maybe
like 352 if that had yeah exactly and
you know Brady realized that he needed
to be made fun of uh I think I think
there's a consensus that Brady had his
pants when he played at Notre Dame up
too high and will called him out and I
think Brady was comfortable with that it
did hurt him in the draft by the way I
think the high pant he dropped he did
drop because of that that was I think so
and he had a terrible uh uh what's the
what's the diagnostic test the
wonderlick wonderlick he had a horrible
wonderlick score you don't know that he
got like a seven I no he did not no no
no no you can't be you can't I can
verify with him I'm on his radio show
later okay ask him what his Wonder I'll
verify these this is the show of record
we can't be loose with this okay your
body's a wonderless no get a five just
for writing your name like the SAT or
automatically you have Brady Quinn
wonderl let's go closest to the hole
quickly I'm GNA go
42 I think I think the max is like 38
and it it's a punter guys think no
there's some extra credit yeah like
there's that there's an I'm go 32 32
wait I thought wonderlick was 50 Pat MC
and only had a 50 did he okay I got will
I got Brady Quinn 29 oh that's above
average but that's right around where he
went in the draft I think he was like
what 20 20 20 22nd maybe something like
that okay wonderlick but they don't have
that for basketball players though no
they don't they have it for baseball
baseball we did a lot of personality
tests and you were drafted by the
Orioles yep so you had to do that but
should there be that kind of test for
basketball players I think so I think it
would be I think it would be very
helpful you know what I okay but would
LeBron be the smartest guy on the
basketball floor uh I don't know if he'd
be the smartest but he'd be pretty close
I mean he does some great stuff off the
court um so I'm talking about like
basketball IQ oh smartest player I think
he's got he might get a perfect score
okay he's got a very high basketball IQ
the first time you guarded him what
happened I blocked him you blocked his
shot I got lucky he I wasn't guarding
him I was a help Defender he didn't yeah
yeah he didn't see me I remember it was
in Portland yeah do do you have a
picture of it um I don't know if I have
a picture of it it was the same game
Sorry Yousef that he dunked on Yousef
nerkish pretty pretty aggressively if
any of you remember that that one was I
was on the bench for that part though
that one so you block LeBron you got a
piece of LeBron I got a piece of it made
a three a possession or two later uh and
then that was pretty much all I remember
from that game what what was your
welcome to the NBA moment uh my welcome
to the NBA moment was actually being a
kid growing up in Boston uh I got to
play against Paul Pierce in my first
year um I wasn't playing much it was
kind of scrub minutes uh but I was on
the free throw line next to him it might
have even been preseason uh and I said
to him hey for my 10-year-old birthday
you gave me one of your game worn
sweatbands that said the truth number 34
uh and that meant a lot to me like thank
you so much and he goes dude you make me
feel really old right now don't tell me
that story I said oh my bad my bad my
bad but what's it like guarding guys
that you grw up watching and hoping to
get into the league uh it's really cool
I mean look I'm a competitive guy so uh
when I'm on the court I don't really
have the moment as much but uh when you
look back on it or when you think about
it before the game and I'm looking at
the sheet trying to obviously know their
first move second move third move uh
it's it's a pretty surreal thought uh
and I think you know the hardest guy
that I've ever had had to guard and it
wasn't my matchup it was Drew holiday's
matchup was uh and PJ Tucker's match up
was Kevin Durant like oh there's only so
much I can do if he misses a shot it's
it's because he missed not because I
really did a whole lot what is the
scouting report on Kevin Durant um do
the best you can yeah play but is he if
we look at Unstoppable yeah how many
guys would you put in that
category you know I put my teammate
Giannis in that category you know even
on his bad nights he's probably putting
up 25 and 12 um I'd put Kevin Durant in
that category uh you know I think when
you think Unstoppable you think of guys
like Shaq right back in the day most
dominant guys you think of those types
of players uh I think in today's day and
age you got to look at guys like joic
not necessarily just because he can
score but what he does with the game
like you can't explain that Pat explain
joic to me like if I if nobody saw if I
didn't see him and you go okay I'm going
to tell you who the best player in the
game is y he can't run can't jump uh but
he he's unsto able so let me say his he
would have a perfect score on on the
what is it the wonder wonder wonderlick
yeah yeah so just basketball IQ
basketball IQ he makes everyone around
him better he obviously has great
individual moves individual skill um but
he wants you to send two guys he wants
you to double team them triple team them
because it makes the game easy for him
he doesn't have to move that much he can
pick you apart and then he can kind of
go to work and do what he does well
what's Luca like
Luca's tough cuz he's bigger than you
think Luca is I would say similar size
to to Paul Pierce in my opinion um but
he's a point guard yeah he's and he's
strong he's strong and so I think uh
trying to guard him and he just kind of
put you on his hip and there's not a
whole lot you can do and when he can hit
hit his step back at a consistent rate
which he's been doing uh it's really
hard to stop I saw where Steph Curry
said he's the best point guard of all
time that just came out yesterday or the
day before yeah um I mean I don't know
that you can argue it I mean oh I can
okay let's hear it like he's not a point
guard shooting guard yeah is what you
think oh absolutely why what defines a
point guard well it used to you ran the
point you ran the team yeah you don't
think he runs that team he's not even
the best passer on the team that's true
I'll give you that I'll give you that
Magic Johnson is by far the greatest
point guard of all time so those would
be the two in my opinion that's the
discussion I think by far is allowed if
you're not defining Steph as a point
guard I do think at the end of the day
Steph has the ball more than Draymond
when it comes to crunch time putting the
team in certain situations gets it to
Draymond and then starts running off
picks but but Draymond does lead the
team in assist he has more assists than
Steph does magic magic could have gotten
25 a night he could have gotten 30 a
night I mean he's 69 he's just backing
people down he could do whatever he want
but he was so he was selfless now I love
Steph he changed basketball yep uh but
he's not a point guard
he's he's just a great basketball player
we don't have designations any anymore
right we don't have positions but it
used to be and that's why I argued with
the commissioner I said why do you have
two forwards a center and two guards for
all NBA because it Luca can be a forward
at some point in the game he could be a
a point guard Kevin Durant can be a two
and he could be a three and he can be a
four I don't think you need
designations because it felt like Rudy
goar would be on the first second or
third Team all NBA because he played
center but he wasn't one of the top 15
players in the game so when you talk
about point guards I guess my question
to you would then be just because Steph
may not lead his team in assists okay
does that still not Define him as a
point guard if he's able to pass the
ball and Lead be second third on his
team and assists because we still have
point guards on our team that don't lead
our team and assists if he was 65 he
would be just a shooting guard yep but
because he's smaller we think the
smallest guy on the floor is the point
guard yeah but he's not not I mean he's
an anomaly he's you know there there's
nobody like him but magic Magic's the
greatest point guard of all time I think
it's a good conversation I think it's a
good conversation I I I lean towards
Steph but I I'd put magic second on my
list what's it like guarding Steph uh
it's it's really hard it's really
exhausting uh you know he just he never
stops moving I mean I know you guys have
probably seen the clips but he always
moves and uh when he passes the ball he
actually like moves faster uh and so uh
he's in he's incredible to watch I love
watching film of him I love watching how
he's able to G regain his balance for
his jump shot no matter where he is on
the floor no matter how fast he's moving
uh and then obviously him having to him
having the ability to shoot the ball
from so far you got to guard him so far
it makes him faster makes him quicker
puts him in a position where I always
say people talk about Kyrie Irving has
having the best Handles in the league
and I and I think that might be true but
when you talk about having the best
handles for your game it's Steph every
every time he bounces the ball it's like
a a pass to himself he could shoot it at
any time and so to me his handle is the
best handle for his game what's the
story you'll tell your kids about
Giannis oh there's a few of them uh the
one I'll tell my kids about that's that
makes me look good
is okay I'm all right with that um and
it's a credit to him right uh he got to
where he is because of work he get to
where he is because of um you know the
amount of hours he put in the gym so
when I first got to milwa I had gotten
waved by Portland didn't get a
qualifying offer signed with him as a
free agent one year team option vet
minimum uh and I still had to try to
make it and this was five years ago and
so you go in in September right before
training camp you're there for about two
or three weeks uh and you start to play
pickup you do like a lift in the morning
you play pickup and then guys leave the
gym and so for me because of what I have
to do to to survive and to be a you know
prominent role player in the NBA uh I go
to the gym at night too try to put up an
extra 500 shots 600 700 shots whatever
the case may be so do I yeah just like
you I'm always at the gym at 1100 a.m.
tomorrow right oh yeah yeah up um and so
I go back in the gym and I just start
shooting and jannis walks in the gym and
he looks at me uh and I can't do his
Greek tent but he goes what are you
doing here and I kind of looked around
like no no no what are you doing here
like you're about to win your first MVP
like and uh he goes I always come back
at night like I got to get better at
shooting like that's that's what is
going to help me be the best basketball
player I can be and I said well I want
to stay in the league so this is why I'm
here shooting extra shots right uh and
to his credy goes I've never had
somebody that I could come back to shoot
with like I want to come back I want to
shoot with you we do extra lifts at
night and so to see the amount of work
he put in it was I had to do it to to
become a player in the league to
solidify myself to get a second and
third contract he was doing it because
he just wanted to be the best player he
could be he didn't judge himself against
anybody else it was all about how can I
be the best that I can be and how can I
help my team win and what are some of
the deficiencies that I think I need to
get better at um and look I'm not going
to take full credit but since I got the
NBA 5 years ago he's won two MVPs he
won all right okay something to be said
yeah Pat conon takes credit for
giannis's great okay I like it get out
there yes will are you still surprised
though at the number of younger players
who don't get that uh I am I think you
know the the shift that I've seen and
again I'm I'm 30 now so I'm not a young
guy surprisingly enough but um but you
can still dunk right Pat yes I can still
dunk yep don't worry I can still do that
okay good the second I can second I
can't do that I might go back to
baseball but um or play golf with Steph
but I would say they like to do the work
that people see they like to do the work
that is on Instagram and things of that
nature but it's the extra time 100% how
much time have how many times have you
seen a clip of Giannis putting an extra
work on Instagram not as much but I can
tell you he does it every single day
right and you might see a picture of him
in the gym where he looks like the
Incredible Hulk but like he doesn't
really post all of the extra work that
he does because to him it doesn't really
matter like doing the extra work just
gets you there like it's you got to
continue to do it you got to want to do
it you got to love it uh let me mention
Pat's Foundation has a mission of
creating uh access to Athletics for the
next generation of student athletes
through clinics and courts and character
and over the last eight years the
foundation has impacted over 18,000
student athletes and for more
information Pat conon Uh I'm going to
have to spell that in case you're not
familiar c o n n a u g h t o n they must
have butchered your name growing up
didn't they yeah the worst one I got was
cunning offington
usually it's like the GH gets confused
for a pH or the G looks like an I've
never had both that was the first time I
had both yeah uh it's great to see you
thanks for joining us and good luck with
your foundation in this upcoming you're
under contract I'm under contract for
three more years oh so money money that
extra work with Yiannis I tell you I
like let go open invite anybody wants to
come to a Bucks game we roll the red
carpet for you guys get you hey that's
awesome we'll give you 24 jerseys you
probably want 34 jerseys but that's all
right we give you 24 can we can we shoot
in the layup line you can shoot in the
layup line like the day before so like
at the arena the day before we can get
you some jump shots up cuz I like to
shoot the layup and then hit the
backboard when I only do a layup line
they have to do a strict layup line
correct it's got to be one guy and the
rebounder pass it to the next guy take
one shot because I'd like to do a little
shooting Clinic if I could yeah
absolutely okay 100% maybe the maybe the
kids of my clinic should be learning
from
you you know just they call me the Irish
freak oh I like that yeah yeah just the
Irish freak that's good for strictly for
athleticism reason do with basketball
okay want to check it out well
appreciate you guys having thank you for
joining us Pat conon the buck shooting
guard we'll take a break back after this